foreign
[Music]
Bloody Mary because it starts off with
pepper vodka and on the glasses we are
going to do celery salt so I'm crazy
this way why is she the way that she is
guys I'll pour this onto a plate it's
just perfect delicious if you're
drinking out of the glass now equal
parts of pepper vodka oh or more vodka
than vegetable juice
did you see that and did you hear that
did you hear and see what she just said
did you see her Sly wink to the camera
listen to this onto a plate it makes it
delicious if you're drinking all the
glass now equal parts of pepper vodka
or more vodka than vegetable juice
a little slide mama's gonna make a
little strong for you isn't she
yeah I bet you every drink she hands a
person they go oh thank you
one of these to do the oh thank you so
much
a little strong
you like
now if you don't want to have a bloody
mary that has alcohol you want to know I
like the bar by my house you know which
one my karaoke you know there's so much
that's when I go and I normally
sometimes if I go there early I'll get
like um
a Tito's in like a sugar-free Red Bull
or something
and now that you want to double I'm like
yeah and then they just fill the entire
glass now with like it's like a triple
right and then they just hand me a
sugar-free Rebel they go here you go
make your own I'm like thank you that's
so kind of you I like to make them in my
mouth
here you go make your own I will thank
you
turn your body away first while still
looking at them and then you turn your
head away the fancy voice so happy I do
one of these yeah is
on it you could certainly make a virgin
Bloody Mary and what you're going to add
to this a tablespoon of the jalapeno
juice no very nice with that pepper
jalapeno juice is what you call a Jewish
Mexican vodka and we're going to add a
teaspoon of horseradish no it's a bloody
mary I mean it might not be bad for a
bloody mary but the issue with a bloody
Mary it's it's too um thin
do you know what I mean I don't like
Bloody Mary's um I but I know people
that do and whatever and now they're
getting out ridiculous now the Bloody
Mary comes an entire [ __ ] homemade
pizza on it and full chicken and bacon
and Sliders you've seen those right yeah
it's ridiculous
and bro just eat a chicken
stop putting so many things on your
Bloody Mary just eat a whole chicken
Royce Lopez 2022.
uh oh yeah no you're right uh but it's
true though
just you don't oh no someone stuffed
this chicken with a burger oh no oh no
yeah you're right what I was saying was
a joke and not based on something that I
actually have seen in real life for
example this so yeah what the [ __ ]
that's a bloody Mary with a whole
chicken I knew exactly I I I mine was
the one I saw was I saw one in real life
but it wasn't fried it was uh rotisserie
you know
but same same concept right yeah I'm
serious bro this is a real thing and
like it's like and and there's this
place in Orlando that I went to
that lets you make your own so you know
you pick your Bloody Mary and then you
pick the toppings and you'll get stuff
that looks like this like I'm not even
kidding you like this isn't like a joke
there's places that have this and guess
what oh I'm sorry you have a date okay
then why don't both of you eat a whole
[ __ ] chicken I don't know I don't
know whatever buddy Mary she's [ __ ]
Christ why are there two cornish game
hens on top of it I don't know Frozen
reminds me of that joke in Frasier
bloody Mary bloody hell
foreign
[Music]
I hate you
um
they're getting out of hand and we
really need to do something about this
guys these things are getting out of
hand what is this why this this is
getting out of control right we're
getting out of control
now we gotta look this up are they
starting to learn Frozen Can you look
that up we need another 911 guys we're
getting too cocky with our Bloody Marys
foreign
biscuit of 2023 it's like Bloody Mary's
have gotten out of hand okay
why don't you just order a bloody Mary
and get these things on the side look
everything on that looks good right
but yeah just not on a stick in a drink
put it on a plate God damn it
I'm so angry
I'm sorry Sandra I apologize there we go
you don't have to be exact
take this and Stir It Up When are you
ever yeah to your glasses I have already
cut up some of these lemons which you
can also garnish with if you like but
what I like to do is put them on the rim
of the glass like that and then put this
into the celery salt and make it nice
and deep
oh now ice in these
because you want these very cold when
you serve them
and if you wanted to you could freeze
the vegetable juice that way you don't
dilute your
cocktail wow anything anything anything
not to water down mommy's boots
oh what
what is this simple juice is when a
Jewish person's in a coma
ooh like Terry shivosting
no Frozen you're gonna make him mad what
is this when Jerry posted this
outrageous history on Facebook we had to
see it today hold on hold on no
no no no
no no you don't put sweet stuff baby you
don't put sweet stuff you don't put
sweet stuff you don't put sweet stuff on
a bloody mary you don't put sweet stuff
on a bloody mary there's also one with
Babybel cheeses on them wait is that a
bagel separating the sweet from yep it's
even still no because now I have eclair
on my bagel yeah I'm not happy and now I
have Phil no Facebook we had to see it
to believe it we're at Crystal Lake Rib
House and we say oh Jason's gonna kill
her babe The Best For Last God willing
this is uh this is this this food shows
on shutter where they go where they go
to places where where uh they go to
places where horror movies are made and
they go to restaurants there we're here
on
here on kids are being murdered in their
dreams but you know what else is being
murdered taste buds with the best cherry
pie in the [ __ ] State Amityville
known for shark attacks those have a
great seafood place and we're gonna be
visiting today
[Music]
you've all seen a Serbian film well I
got something to tell you Serbia is not
just known for its brutal baby death
pornography movies it's also known for
its schnitzel you've been to Moscow and
been to a hostel you know it's not
hostile the service at this wing place
I've seen pictures of this Bloody Mary
there are so many toppings a hot dog
just a loose hot dog
dude I'd sneeze and it what if it all
fall what if it falls but my point is
this like what okay even if that was in
a place it's too much food for a single
man
yeah
that's too much food for five men do you
share the food and then fight over who
drinks the no Bloody Mary crumbs
everyone gets yeah I'm sorry oh wow I'm
sorry buddy I got some some locks and
some frosting in your Bloody Mary hope
that doesn't ruin it for you
can't even count all of them by the time
we get to the stuff that's been sitting
in the Bloody Mary it's soggy but yeah
and not only not only that but think
about this all the hot stuff like it's
gonna be cold but you know what I mean
100. I've always wanted one onion ring
so the hot food is gonna cool down the
Bloody Mary which has ice in it but it's
all but but so it's going to heat up the
Bloody Mary which has ice in it and the
Bloody Mary is going to cool off the
food and make it soggy this is great no
no this is way better than having food
on a plate like we've had you know since
the beginning of ever
David facon Ho Ho he's a [ __ ] going all
right 100 items on the Bloody Mary it
started out as a just a little cone does
sound like an Italian slur doesn't it
hey you're being a real [ __ ] God over
here
yeah
and you heard about uh you heard about
uh Betty's son yeah I heard it was uh
it's always a problem getting everything
to stay in there so now we have this
little system where we can put
everything on there it stays balanced
it's great so they so they're buttons
yes I know their bloody marys have
gotten so out of control
so out of control
that they've needed to invent and
manufacture and weld the product to be
able to hold all the ridiculous stuff
knowing full well we already have plates
yeah so we actually genetically modified
our Bloody Mary's so that they would
just stand next to you kill me
kill me please
sir I can't think
I love that that's these Bloody Mary's
office for Barb Brady I put a little
flavor ribs on there oh no they're gonna
put ribs Donuts I've got pastries well
as I'm finishing it everybody who's
still here is coming over and going let
me take a picture with the Bloody Mary I
mean it's a spectacle so I take a
picture of it three and a half million
hits it's three and a half a million on
a glass
I've never seen so many different foods
balanced on a mod how do you keep it up
there like that are you using some sort
of magic or something we're not from the
big city so we don't know how these
sticks work in Bloody Mary's Leonard
look at that the drink is spicy with
tomato but there's a donut up there it's
not just all the wildest thing Leonard
and Leonard's looking at a waitress's
ass
it's crazy yeah
and then when they come up what do you
want she's short as a wacky Bloody Mary
and he goes I'll take the ribs and in a
goddamn plate
do you hear me I'll take a Miller High
Life and ribs
so and then yeah and then she reaches
for his fries and with a mouthful of
ribs he smacks her hand and goes I
should have put fries on your [ __ ]
weird drink yeah
what's wrong you could have put potato
wedges on your on your [ __ ] diluted
V8 with vodka in it you [ __ ] [ __ ]
huh we need to write a realistic sitcom
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] Christ where are they from
Montana they're from Montana
hey can you put having sex with me more
than once a month on that Bloody Mary
maybe you pay attention to me
well maybe if the well maybe if the
Bloody Mary looked more like my sister
you look at it more
oh yeah well me well your sister doesn't
need Bloody Mary's like that Patty all
right hey who's the [ __ ] home that made
this
[Laughter]
get him over here
me my wife me and my wife came to have a
beautiful dinner and you put in hot dogs
and bagels on a drink and now I feel
like less of a man
foreign
and then he goes oh good so you also
told them my dick don't work
what what are you why
ah great
this is worse than the time you got
stuck in the elevator with no clothes
but you're just gonna tie it off
[Laughter]
story lines
Patty if you're gonna sit there and if
you're gonna sit there and glare at me
can you eat that pickle quieter
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
look at that Bloody Mary guys that is
dude that is an Abomination you didn't
see it earlier there's a crab cloth oh I
no I saw the Crab Claw oh I saw the Crab
Claw it looked like it was reaching for
one of the donuts
here wow again so we have to worry about
that if you have sex right Patty
paper you know what you need to clip now
oh yeah so you'll experiment with a
bloody mary but when I bring a girl home
you won't do that
I love this I love that this Bloody Mary
is just ruining a relationship bringing
a girl home landed that you it's the
babysitter you [ __ ] idiot Jesus
he's 21.
that's not the why are you being oh
that's not the point so I can't look at
a 21 year old hot rod but you can eat a
[ __ ] pretzel mozzarella sticks in a
V8 bath oh yeah that's fine that's
normal God forbid I come
[Music]
then it's
and then
splash splash she goes she goes what do
you mean God forbid you come I've been
faking it Patty
[Laughter]
a waiter just comes up so are you are
you all enjoying your meal shut the [ __ ]
up hey let me tell you something to you
I've been faking it why do you think
there's so many empty cans of condensed
milk next to the bed what do you think
about splashing on your back
you stupid [ __ ] why do you think my
cum's so sweet yeah yeah yeah well you
have any mustard for your [ __ ] weird
drink pretzel you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
yeah I think so
hey can I get a burger on a plate and a
beer you know like a normal person
and maybe somebody back there'll jerk me
off my wife ain't doing it
um sir we've gotten a complaint from the
tip from the your adjacent table I know
she's a type of [ __ ] I know yeah I got
it yeah first off at the other table I
got a prime tell her to one of these
[ __ ] ridiculous Bloody Marys they
won't be able to see me or hear me
through them well I tell you what why
don't you build a wall of [ __ ] hens
and donuts and maybe you won't hear me
through you dumb [ __ ] how about that
huh
you're you're upsetting the children on
table fives yeah that's [ __ ] good you
got a kid's version is [ __ ] Bloody
Mary all children another thing we'll
never had because that can't come
God your tail but you're just [ __ ]
terrible shut up Patty shut up
yeah I want you to eat everybody first
off he looks 70 dollar Bloody Mary
shut up shut up Patty eat your pretz oh
you're on the ribs now yeah oh cool oh
cool a seventy dollar bloody berry but I
want to order the UFC fight and all of a
sudden we can't afford it
yeah I know maybe make a little more
money if you weren't [ __ ] sitting at
home all day watching Law YouTube you're
not gonna be a lawyer Patty
no but please renew your audible
subscription for some more True Crime
podcasts you stupid [ __ ] you know who
did it the dumb [ __ ] that knew they
could sell these murders to you
give a [ __ ] True Crime dump [ __ ]
walking Mumble or mumbling going to the
bathroom
spoiler alert it's 20 22. Thomas been
[ __ ] dead for years
oh oh my God
and that has been your episode of the
Bloody Mary's well they're called the
Bloody Marys that's the name of it
actually it's somebody said this sounds
like there's a succumb called the
guineas from Hoboken
oh
I told you raised pizza with an a not
with an E you dumb [ __ ]
Leonard and Patty Guinea yeah exactly
meet the guineas
[Music]
and then and then and then somebody
walks after all that screaming goes why
someone have spy goes man your wife's a
real [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
mother of my children
tries to stab him with a bloody mary
stick
um sir here's your bill
you take dinosaur Club
look like a dinosaur but it's cover
which one do you want
we'll take the discovery sir all right
good I also don't have my Discover
dynast Club sorry
um
we just we just conjured up the two
worst [ __ ] people in America they're
both equally terrible I think those two
people I think you put lefties and
righties in a [ __ ] room yeah with
those two people will unite everyone
will do the looking at each other
nodding that they're the problem you
know what I mean the
politics
doing the it doesn't matter it could be
like a [ __ ] two completely different
people and both of them will be doing
the
all this time we were fighting about
politics when we when the worst thing in
America was actually wearing sweatpants
at 12 30 in the afternoon